Welcome to the WebAudio API lesson! I personnally love this API, playing with it is a lot of fun
as you will discover! I hope you will like it as much as I do!
The audio and video elements are used for playing streamed content, but we do not have a real
control on the audio. They come with a powerful API as we saw during the previous course and
the previous lessons of this course: we can build a custom user interface, make our own play,
stop, pause buttons. We can control the video from JavaScript, listen to events
and manage playlists, etc. However, we have no real control on the audio signal: fancy visualizations
are impossible to do. The ones that dance with the music, and sound effects such as
reverberation, delay, make an equalizer, control the stereo, put the signal on the left
or on the right is impossible. Furthermore, playing multiple sounds in sync is nearly impossible
due to the streamed nature of the signal. For video games, we will need to play very
fast different sounds, and you can not wait for the stream to arrive before starting playing it.
Web Audio is the solution to all these needs
and with Web Audio you will be able to get the output signal from the audio and video elements,
and process it with multiple effects. You will be able to work with samples loaded
in memory. This will enable perfect syncing, accurate loops, you will be able to mix
sounds, etc. You can also generate music programmatically
for creating synthetic sounds or virtual instruments. This part will not be covered by this course
even if I give links to interesting libraries and demos that do that.
Let’s have a look at some applications. The first thing I wanted to show you is just
want we can do with the standard audio element. So this is the standard audio element [music]
that just plays a guitar riff that is coming from a server, but we can get control on the audio
stream and do such things like that [music]. As you can see I control the stereo balancing here,
and we have a real time waveform and volume meters visualization.
Another thing we can do is that we can load samples in memory.
This is an application I wrote for playing multitracks songs. So we are loading MP3s and
decoding them in memory so that we can click anywhere on the song, I can make loops like this [music].
As you can see,
we can isolate the tracks, we can mix them in real time.
Another application that works with samples in memory is this small example you will learn
how to write it in the course: we loaded two different short sounds [sounds] in memory
and we can play them repeatedly [sounds] or we can add effects like changing the pitch, changing
the volume with some random values and play them with random intervals [sounds].
We can see that the application to video games is straightforward.
Another thing you can do is use synthetics sounds, we will not cover the techniques,
but you can use some libraries. This is a library that works with synthetic
sounds, you do not have to load a file for having these sounds [sounds].
This is a library for making 8 bits sounds like the very first computers and video games
in the 80's used to produce. You can also make very complex application,
like a vocoder [sounds], or a synthesizer music instrument [sounds]. Ok you have got the idea.
This is all the interesting things you can do, and you can also learn how to debug such
applications. I will make a video especially for that, but using FireFox, you can activate,
in the setting of the dev tools, the Web Audio debug tab.
So I clicked here on Web Audio, and this added a new tab here Web Audio, and if I reload the
page, I can see the graph corresponding to the route of the signal.
Here we have got a source -this is called the audio graph- so we've got the source,
and we've got a destination. The source is the original sound. In that
case it is a mediaElementAudioSource node that corresponds to the audio element here.
The signal goes to an other node that is provided by the Web Audio API and implemented natively in
your browser, it is a StereoPanner for separating the sound between left and right.
So then it goes to an analyser here that will draw the blue waveform and finally to the
destination, and the destination is the speakers. I also routed the signal to another part of
the graph just for displaying two different analysers corresponding to the left and right
channels. This is for the volume meters here [music].
And if you click on a node, you can see that some node have parameters.
On the stereoPanner, that enables me to balance the sound to the left or to the right, you
can see if I change that and click again, I can debug the different properties of each
node. You will learn how to build this graph,
how to assemble the different nodes, what are the most useful nodes for adding effects,
controlling the volume, controlling the stereo, making a equalizer, creating fancy visualizations,
and so on. Welcome to the Web Audio world and during a
few lessons, you will learn step by step how to do such an application.